[Musique]
dans le petit monde du show business on
peut penser que tout le monde s'entend
très bien et pourtant derrière les
sourires de façade
parfois les masques dont ben ça fait un
moment que la tension monte doucement
entre l'animateur cauet la chanteuse
angèle alors que la jeune belge aurait
une première fois refusé de faire une
vidéo de l'animateur s'est cette fois ci
un nouveau refus de participer à sa
collecte d'objets de stars pour venir en
aide aux personnels hospitaliers qui a
fait sortir de ses gonds cauet en direct
sur nrj il s'en est pris directement à
angèle elle s'en fout elle n'est pas
touché par le truc à les toucher porte
pas grand chose je pense qui la touche
mais celle qui allie non ces engins
avant d'ajouter dire non alors que c'est
pour remettre de l'argent à une
association alors qu'on est en pleine
épidémie on a en pleine pandémie on sait
c est cher la seule qui a dit non mais
si jusqu'à maintenant la chanteuse
n'avait pas souhaité répondre aux
différentes attaques de cauet c'est la
goutte d'eau qui a fait déborder le vase
attaquer directement sur son manque de
solidarité envers le personnel soignant
cette période de crise
angèle a souhaité remettre les pendules
à l'heure si je n'ai pas accepté la
demande c'est parce que je suis confiné
depuis le début hors de chez moi et que
je joue le jeu d'un confinement total
je ne repasserai pas à mon appartement
en belgique et n'encourageraient
personne à le faire à ma place
avant d'expliquer qu'elle aider les
personnes dans le besoin d'une autre
manière par ailleurs de mon côté j'ai
décidé de soutenir ce qui se passe
autrement en agissant en direct auprès
d'associations médicale en faisant des
dons pour acheter des respirateurs qui
viennent à manquer dans les hôpitaux
notamment une réponse pour le moins
courtois sauf que voilà le rappeur romeo
et de vie ce qui n'est autre que le
frère d'ange elle n'a pas non plus
supporter les attaques répétées de cauet
du coup il a posté sur instagram
tu es une merde sans nom un minable un
gamin quand j'étais petit tu passais
déjà à la télé je te trouvais déjà lourd
là tu es devenu une énorme merda
susceptible bref pas sûr qu il fasse
tout de suite appel à angèle pour sa
prochaine idée à l'antenne voilà voilà
alors bon alors ça ça un buzz et tout le
week end qu est en poste chez nous alors
connaissant cauet c'est quelqu'un de
droit
c'est quelqu'un qui n'invente pas c'est
quelqu'un qui se mobilisent pour les
causes pour qu'il dise ça c'est vraiment
qu'il a eu a reçu et je trouve que dans
les excuses le texte le communiqué
d'angel on voit qu'elle tente de se
justifier
donc je pense qu'elle a mésestimé
l'importance de l'appel action commune
est qu elle qu'elle est en tant qu elle
tente de s'en sortir mais extrêmement la
du mal je trouve qu'elle a mésestimé
l'action de kohat
c'est sa vie qu elle sait qu il n ya pas
assez soutenu fouet
non mais après elle a dit qu'elle
faisait d'autres actions apparaît
qu'elle avait pas envie de participer à
ça mais c'est vrai quand zeljko et c'est
la guerre qui est en principe un jardin
là mais je peux aussi a parfois refusé
des choses aux postes importants qui a
balancé en direct par le par l'animateur
ça nous arrive à tous à vous avez pas
vous serez arrêtés en balance ou non
n'est pas donné à quelqu'un webb est ce
que vous êtes l'élever monsieur n'ont
pas arrêté il a le droit de balancer la
turquie ap qu'il a fait couler quand on
parle des données